let's do this man welcome welcome to
your Monday Corona free zone Brendan
Corona free its Corona free we don't
talk about Corona on this podcast we
[ __ ] just move forward you know I'm
saying can I say one thing sure bro yeah
once can I say one thing yeah it's been
circulating circulating around our group
Tex
oh yes Brogan post it do you see Falchi
Tom up mask mask said said yeah it
doesn't help they don't work don't work
yeah well we're all wearing them we're
all wearing them no we're not not I'm
not well not this morning coffee can put
a mask on it I'm just gonna leave sorry
Sam I'm just gonna leave you said I'm
gonna sleep and then I get coffee from
[ __ ] there they go
all right that's how that's how it is
play this for me Jen then we'll move on
ah right now in the United States people
should not be walking around with masks
you're sure of it because people are
listening really no when was this right
now people should not be worried there's
no reason to be walking around when was
this good question when you're in the
middle as I said March panda bearing a
mask might make people feel a little bit
better and it might even block a droplet
but it's not providing the perfect
protection that people think that it is
and often there are unintended
consequences people keep fiddling with
the mask and they keep touching their
face and can you get some schmutz sort
of staying inside there and fish schmutz
laws but when you think mask you should
think of health care providers needing
them and people who are ill right Nick
ANCA the way your stupid masks but they
cause person says here
Korver a million default quiz that
doesn't slide that's what he said back
in March said make you cover the face
frustrating well they say one thing they
do another they say this but then don't
you see all of our government officials
none of them are ever wearing it well
also like who's making these can I just
listen in on some of these decisions
that are made in these boardrooms and
also stop wearing masks on the goddamn
by trails now everybody else snakes
don't have Cove in or they'll have it
off and then when you're a thousand
yards away they see a human they put the
mask there just trying to not get mask
shamed now it's like not getting shamed
I don't wanna get
asked shamed well you need a master name
if you don't dude I just came up with a
[ __ ] brand in a business mask mask
mask list help me with what the viewers
know Brian saw the insanely worldwide
success Thicke boy by Club pathetic and
you don't make me mad but yeah it's it's
it's very success thank you oh no big
deal yeah made a business during this
all right here's the thing though dude
so now Brian's won't stop pestering me
to come up with a business idea I'm an
entrepreneur when I say you're the worst
entreprenuer in the world well you bad
okay I understand that I'm Steve Jobs
yeah you don't have a job I understand
that I'm not that good right now but
like with everything you learn it takes
a long time and I think I'd like some
years now I'm ready to bust out never
had a good I listen first of all guys
there's a huge [ __ ] this stupid crazy
like then boy then we're cruisers you
know thank you for that say thank you
but I can't like that's that's Brennan's
idea I'm not gonna bite thi n and end
boy we sell Cruiser put hey Dan by
Christmas we don't bike but we walk we
stroll through all life's to strew don't
do anything then boy I got a scroll yeah
so not starting at Twilight cruisers
work by the end of this [ __ ] podcast
I'm gonna come up with a [ __ ] company
and I'm gonna come up with a [ __ ]
product I said it and if I don't if I
don't nothing's gonna happen I'm gonna
[ __ ] throw my face into that watch
into that [ __ ] table I'd like that
and I'm gonna flatten my own face oh oh
oh I like that
Oh could be a good point you you did
give daddy the initial startup for you
to start my merchandise business you
gave me you gave me two grand to create
find the kid sure how do you give me the
initial investment I forgot about that
so you got your money back
I say you got your money back and I do
some would even say you still make a ton
of money well but about that what if you
wet my house was gonna forget about that
the bike don't need anymore
but what if you well I'm thin what would
have on the mascot and you don't have a
snake think about it think of
it can paint you like a little snake yes
like a couple of Viper dude nope okay a
rattler nope okay a gardener yes I don't
even get to be a rattler mm-hmm I give
you a card nur you'll be a little stupid
garnet ain't gonna make me one scared of
it are you gonna make me like this and
wiggle around we're gonna glue your
hands to your side really gonna tape
your hands to your side what do I make
for that no no you don't make anything
it's just part of the business piece of
the company it's mark I need to buy a
house I'm having house problems as you
know I'm having the house pretty bribry
needs money well what's good is when
they lay down to put a bathtub in and a
floor in and then like that's like real
work takes a long time and then you turn
the shower on and in two weeks later you
got a leak a faucet coming out of your
garage that's not that's not good yeah
cuz then suddenly you hired two smart
workers yeah sure do you cut in cutting
corners there papa you get what you pay
for
get we paid for what I should do in the
future is when I hire a project manager
who I've worked with for two years and
then I said hey I got a great person
what I should do Jeff the only thing I
should just maybe see if that contractor
has a license yeah that's a plus it's
just a license kind of need it in it I
would imagine so there were a lot of
issues that I overlooked but you know
you get busy and sometimes all you can
do is trust I'm busy writing stand up
coming up with my own company like thin
boy cruisers there's a lot of stuff I'm
doing yeah I don't have time to [ __ ]
check all your credentials I trust that
you can do the work they trust you're
too trustworthy yeah well people I now
know why some people like Rogan don't
trust anybody didn't trust anybody but I
understand because he sees I see the
best in people me till he sees their
liabilities immediately it's probably
better be on road inside if you're like
I want to save money and learn you save
time I've paid a lot of money because
I've done favors for people that I
wanted to give the benefit of the doubt
to yeah you know one time a year the guy
he was like you can borrow my Prius he's
like thanks dude i'ma leave the keys in
the car though I go inside sometimes
that happens too sometimes that oh and
then sometimes you come by and just take
the car and that cost me a lot of money
would you think papa yeah
cost me a lot of money because when your
car gets stolen but then it gets
retrieved there's damage you find crack
pipes in it did I show you the video
no I found crack pipes under the listen
no one's deal a Prius lodged in cracker
that's exactly right and it smells like
now do you think the first red flag
Nelson gret your friend who I don't know
forty plus they can't afford a car do
you think that was maybe a few red flags
a lot of red flags but I'm red flags
he's like really give it to me but I was
like sure he's like thanks dude yeah
that's why I should actually start a
company called skinny skinny Santa Claus
where I don't make any money but I the
my company gives money away oh it's a
good company could start getting all bad
choices bad choices is good do you have
an idea I'll buy it yeah that's right
yeah skinny Santa Claus are you a [ __ ]
do you need money here you go that might
be good just like make a wish that story
of my life it's like make a wish but we
just help [ __ ] up yeah really [ __ ]
up people my my ex used to say the miss
Vince she called him my misfits yeah but
I have a lot of misfits I have in the
past had yeah after a while you get over
and you're like I can't do this too much
but I just almost did it just in yeah
yeah maybe we'll figure it out you'll be
fine dude we get enough fun always fine
always fine but cost me money and causes
me a lot of angst and disappoint less
stress yeah I don't know if I'll ever be
different I try to change the
personality types just it's better be
that way then if you're just an ass well
I'm not helping anybody out yeah but but
but like I'm sure that guy learned ok
next time I get a car I'm not gonna
leave the keys in it
yeah and then go party I'm not gonna do
that it isn't really how he's never get
another car again but if he were to ya
knows not to do that then it raises a
really important question like should
you ever help an adult oh yeah yeah for
sure
what about yeah I mean I I do but I
can't help myself
I do and I but but but you should help
if they need like that get in in the car
he's freaking [ __ ] out he made his
choices he's 40-something years old yeah
well what what it depends I mean I throw
I live in a gym no he's paying to live
in the gym yeah you got it you gonna
find a job man it's almost like you're
enabling him you know there's a reason
why to have a car at his age yeah good
died I like
good guy has a set of skills that we
can't use right it's it's it's um and I
wonder what it is man I wonder I should
do an inventory of all the people I've
tried to learn how are they gonna do for
you know just just the idea of does it
doesn't even is the jihadis squeeze yeah
you helped you took a chance on me took
a chance on a fighter that was [ __ ]
coming off a loss and then you know and
then you know if we're in the race of
life I just you know don't make that
sound effect you don't first if
afterwards don't do that that makes me
mad no but it was like no help and I
went oh here's the seed and then like
SimCity SimCity that great game all
right you son of a [ __ ] I'm in okay how
about you love this
I still chin this I'm below the belt and
we'll get to the fights are you attack
well I'm interested hear your opinion
but so one thing Tiger loves to do with
his dad is watch Rick and Morty there's
cussing in it there's some stuff kids
price chintzy but it's our thing yeah so
the new season Sunday nights so he is
before Betty's papaya once Ricky more
dango the new ones that come on to way
later but I'll watch it tomorrow later
this week and he goes come on can I just
watch one I could you have 15 minutes
you have 15 minutes then we go to bed so
I put on the one where they're doing the
they're emulating the Ocean's eleven
where they're doing a heist right and so
he asked all his old friends to come in
and so he like finds them right and he's
with Morty and more he's like who's that
and then he's like whatever and then all
the guests that he they go you son of a
[ __ ] on man and it's like a highlight
gun you son of a [ __ ] on man so then
earlier in the day right I was quote
Ricky Morty early in the day for the the
previous date Joanna cos hey I'm half
ceviche for the fights and the family
comes over and I go you son of a [ __ ]
I'm in and I walked outside got my bike
Dean's how you got to do so then we
watch that episode and then we're gonna
bag all right tt time for the time for
bed he looks amigos you son-of-a-bitch
on me they copy every [ __ ] on me I go I
could not stop laughing and I was like
dude he can't me dude you can I'm
laughing so he knows he's had trouble oh
dude you can only say that word
Papa I was the only one about don't sit
around kids and these other pants
all-around Papa that's my son and I have
a deal where he used to say anything he
wants around me yeah so when I'm in when
I'm driving him in the car his mouth he
goes shut the [ __ ] up this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm like - take it easy
it's like played a mean son of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] hey hey hey calm down
he just can't wait to start saying it
you son of a [ __ ] all minute he jumps
in bed you son of a [ __ ] let's just
[ __ ] I kept [ __ ] my son fine I'll
go
buckle up okay because I am a girl all
right buckle up yes I am yeah I know I
know I'm just saying buckle up buckle up
in is that I screaming that file
Baga because I shut the [ __ ] up I was
like I deserved that you watch the
fights over our friend Frank Murillo's
house i watch the fights at Frank's now
I got I got a message from our friends
Jeff they went be glad you're not here
he was not I'm not a fighter in the
critique Brennan no I'm not me not me he
is you to rip your hair out no no not me
there was no critiquing for me Frank
Frank loves to critique their boxing
here's the thing and I said to Frank
well they're not boxers they're fighters
big difference so let's start with that
don't I need woozy critiquing Tony first
thing you talk about the guy in less
than eight years I'm sorry what tips did
he have for ah well what we'll wait
Ambrose boy till Frank's on the podcast
oh that would be bad news yeah and we'll
just see what he has I was better though
he does he does he just gets into it he
gets into it yeah
Frank Frank knows better I mean if
anybody you know he loves the sport he
loves fighting um but I had to make fun
of my idea I had to be hey I go hey I go
you're not allowed to do a people are
over it was just he get Machado
myself Frank and Jeff and Jeff and two
other people who are the oh you hands
friends of Higgins blue dinkum no yeah
that's just too many people I like blue
the best he's really he's really cool
brian's friend blue works for the guy
takes people's lives but he stationed in
a size I surprise shot either by John
and I go I've some praise three or four
years ago when we're off a habit and I
met him and I go hey man how about when
that military official was killed and
Trump killed him how stressful were you
and he goes you know here means not use
I know tough times yes dude you have no
idea and this come from this guy who you
you're not anti Trump he's like I don't
agree with 99 percent what he says that
was a bad guy and probably better he did
that yeah and I was like really goes yes
that guy was bad news yeah
and I said how you're on pins and
needles like walking around oscar baizen
or whatever yeah and he was yeah man we
had surveillance on us at all times like
he was very stressed yeah he's
interesting he anytime I want an
information on just his perspective on
global issues I call him you really he's
just so smart so she's got his law
degree from University of Michigan he's
got a lot of [ __ ] going on bill blue the
best his son his son who wrestled a ties
Marshawn for the past two years in that
program it's got cauliflower ear already
at 13 it's [ __ ] three months there's
been yeah hope you enjoyed the fight III
enjoyed might be an understatement
what uh where did when did you start
watching what fight did you guys to I
watched every fight i watch the limbs
I watched the prelims I watched Donald
and Anthony I watched fabrics you ever
do him and Alexia limit yeah Fabrizio
yeah I did we um I didn't see the Carla
Esparza up Michelle Waterson fight god
bless you that's a that's a gift really
don't just moorland yeah Michelle
probably won but it's just not a fun
fight yeah Luke do you see leap percent
De Luca and Nico price I did not I did
not I heard it was unbelievable not a
gift
yep no no that that hurt not a gift that
you missed he's fantastic
yeah he's Jiu Jitsu apparently right was
that was that wrong wrong let's face
right mess this up
Charlie nominal and the medium is camo
shorts yeah what did you think all right
let's start with Francis
I mean his his speed and power you just
Kim he was very kind of like here with
wild yeah just coming
swing the problem is if you if you can't
weather that and you make one he just
touched to the end of his chin and you
honestly landed pretty you gonna sleep I
mean I its waited to meet his coaches
we're probably like dude between 12
weeks but I mean we don't just run
sprints if that's what you're gonna do
yeah like we don't need to do all this
technical training like just coaches are
very technical
are they really yeah yeah you know with
a great game plan I'm sure like hey dude
if you're gonna blitz the [ __ ] at home
like Canyon south we don't need that
right I just you know need coaches your
skin shape and do that yeah it really
did look like it was just a blitz it
looked like almost like a panic of just
coming in I just yeah I think that's
wrong I don't think it's a panic I think
it was zero respect for Rosen strike I
was like oh you're gonna call me out I'm
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of ya
I think he was like he can't do [ __ ] I
think he wasn't scared of its power or
anything and just total disrespect I was
like cool story his speed at his size is
what astonishes make most severely he's
so explosive terrible technique Footwear
it work was off chin in there
I literally think he was like this guy
can't knock him out yeah train through
he's built and probably as athletic if
he were if he was not easy he grew up in
this country easy I'll say it if he grew
up in this country he looks like the
kind of guy who probably be in the NFL
as a he looks like six for 265 yeah I
mean he looks like he's got he looks
like a an NFL player he looks like him
you know like one of those freaks he's a
freak look at him yeah there you go
he's 260 with that built a 95 I would be
willing to bet a lot of money that
that's how he's built I don't believe
he's doing any kind of drugs no I think
the same thing with Louis month it was
fun it's just these people who did he's
just [ __ ] said that muscular some
people are just freaks now I'd like to
see him run a 40 before we put him in
the NFL as a first round draft but again
I think some of that is a lifetime of
running practice you you you know you
can't be born you're born faster you're
born slow there's no you can't really
get you know yeah but yeah I feel like
he has speed I really do and what's this
guy's background kids like his he looks
great any professional key buttons Wow
he got caught he get caught you got
knocked out
mm-hmm they're just playing that
exchange game they just got [ __ ] what
do you do kid what do you do about that
don't go straight back yeah yeah you're
left to the right how much straight back
just what it's about I think you're so
explosive with his background you know
he should be able to go left or right
but he that gate the right hand but he
just went straight in Italian Cajun you
know where to go how
Wow yeah do man
yeah hopefully if I throw a title I and
Ghana was one of those two really
dangerous guys obviously in in the
beginning of the fight and if you can
weather that and wrestle with him I
would imagine the next guy that fights
him if I'm his coach about him the coach
of the next guy fights Michael listen me
right now DC I don't care
you just double-leg him okay you get him
on the back and you'd double leg Hoffman
tough to get him down yeah he's been
working wrestling like a [ __ ]
let me tough he's very tough give me
your world champ no doubt you think so
100% you think he beats he puts
everybody to sleep who's in front of
them steep ADC yeah I think they're
gonna fight and then probably both
retire and then maybe with Jon Jones
there's Francis for the interim you know
he came back that's scary
what's your calling back home we know
God think about it don't fight God then
would you think of crews and uh I think
Henry cejudo is is astonishing and every
time he fights he has a new text better
and better
you see those leg kicks like every time
that guy fights and I think that comes
from being the I think he's the youngest
gold medalist ever in wrestling Lisa
yeah that's incredible
I mean to be winning gold medal in in
wrestling is so ridiculous it's so
ridiculous took four years off and and I
think this is a guy who listens he was
11 years old has been watching the human
body move younger than that yep and he's
been watching how the human body moves
and he's got his learning curve his his
learning curve is crazy high his fight
IQ just because he's been doing it so
long and I think also he's just that
kind of guy it's also called insane
talent he's a [ __ ] amazing athlete
axe
and I think and then you know it was do
you think it was stopped too soon
because Dominick Cruz was on his way up
that's a fair argument it's fair I
always cut side on if they're heavier
guys I always say stop it early
yes like within Ghana as soon as that
dudes lights turn off jump the [ __ ]
yes with Bantam weights and the light
weights and the 25 hours and the fly
weights that I mean you know I go on
it's not like they're gonna hurt each
other and also there's two seconds left
in the round
it's a it's a world championship fight
you could let it go and he was working I
forgot about that
and he was working out he was he was
here's here's my raps kind of going hard
in the paint on social media is it hmm
he is he's also video Dominick like you
know when he got hit with the knee goes
oh I'm sorry strike prevent more CT I
think he's right I personally I think
the stoppage is warranted and here's the
other reason I think so I think that
that et Peterson if it's not that if
it's not that officials usually pretty
legit he's [ __ ] if you look at Dominic
Cruz's face and you're there and I
watched him he took five unanswered
punches 11 11 aren't just punches stop
the fight in my opinion I think it's
better to err on the side of caution
maybe this this time it wasn't 9 times
out of 10 rather you you're on Tasha
right nine times that light weights and
World Championship fighting stomp Cruz I
understand but yeah he generally not
you're right nine times out of ten you
did the right try he's trying to protect
the fighter and I would never you know
Dominick Cruz is always gonna be a
porcupine at him no this is a fake
account just type in his did you type in
his name yeah that's it right there but
you gotta go to Twitter he's kind of
it's going pretty hard in the paint
that's it capabilities look so he looks
like he was a fighter himself I mean
look me in the morning after a night of
drinking smoking and like it's a picture
yeah down to Cruz that's price ran upon
they put a Tom Cruise I thought by
stopping the fight I stop you from
getting CT but I guess not I understand
I don't though I I don't want you
exactly coming zombie
I don't want that out of my rest I have
want that personal engagement with the
fighters hmm Kim as if judges were like
it's only it's unprofessional
it is it's non professional he's being
he's being personal as opposed to just
explain his role of his philosophy see
when he put me in the morning after not
drinking and smoking in the post picture
of him yeah that's that's district ruse
it's disrespectful
yeah and has he fought in the UFC a no
it also compromises his ability now if
he's if he's roughing another foot I
want one of it because I'm at God if I
lose out I got him posting and [ __ ] like
wait go back go back go back
it says Dhamma crews near see post fight
show claims referee Keith here and
smelled like alcohol and cigarettes
during his fight said he wanted to have
referee changed when he stopped in the
cage Wow I step in the gate wow that's
weird
yeah I don't think this Keith Peterson's
do himself any favors by trolling
adjusting I mean uh Dominick Cruz no
it's gonna but the other thing I was
gonna say is I think that Henry wins
that fight regardless yeah
so it was it looking great for him now
so let's take that into account too I
mean I think Dominick was having a
really hard time with those [ __ ] leg
kicks yeah and it didn't look like the
Dominic that were used to either it
looked like you know maybe he was
throwing jabs and kind of up jobs and
things like that but I don't think that
was gonna do much to Andrew say I'm not
worried about that more his footwork he
was that ass on the you know yeah I
can't see that I don't know I don't I
can't see that I'm not good and then
Katie furred know if I can be in with
Eddie and Joe on Saturday yes and I'd
love to ask Eddie I being Toni's coach
I've just thrown in the towel and the
fourth well we're gonna get to that yeah
because I I think that it looked like to
me like what was so impressive about
just engage he is that he looked like he
was doing basic great kicks ridiculous
kicks and then basic boxing just
countering left right hook you know hook
right his angles it's this angles which
aren't big his footwork you know it's
not it's really hard to be that good it
did see he's been with he said I
we're going Trevor Whitman for nine
years so those little subtleties that
you can't really even pick up where he's
stepping when he hits where his head is
that that wasn't even his leg kicks if
you watch the way he was leg kicking his
head was out of like a lot of times when
you leg kick your liability getting
punched in the face with time in life
that [ __ ] would just have his
head it's really hard to deal with him I
thought he fought such a patient perfect
fight you said I mean you said to me I
don't know if you said on that podcast
but you said it's a terrible fight for
Tony yeah because you got a because
Justin just stands there and bangs and
well Tony's gift and what he's amazing
at his number one he he's his endurance
is off the charts number two he's very
creative with his punching number three
he just never lets you breathe he just
keeps coming at you and hits you
everywhere it seems that just engage he
that's not the way to fight just
engaging it's just not the way to fight
cousin okay let's see Justin verse could
be because I watched a you know a voice
I think every fight Tony Ferguson has
ever had he does get hit a lot
I mean he gets taken out he gets hit
it's Johnny's it he likes it anywhere it
doesn't he's like cool you did that to
me for three rounds here how we do these
expect them for the guys to kind of
tailor off right disaster and just think
it just kept them it's tough to do any
and punch in the face man
nothing drains our cardio more than him
punched in yeah I hate seeing he's so
rough I would have to cuz he's just too
tough for his own good yeah that's why
you have cornermen and live to fight
another day
well then the other thing I say with a
lot of respect but it's but I just have
to say it I don't believe anybody I
don't care how great you are
I don't believe that anybody can take a
beating that he took from just engag
and not be different afterwards agree
yeah III just I've seen it I don't think
evidence is on your side you look at JD
s when he fought cane yes gets T pay
when he fought Francis gana remember yes
he did work and threats ain't a ton of
shots yeah he gets knocked out in the
following fight against DC against not
that hard of a punch yeah that's right
hey we can go through I can I could come
on yeah and and that's just how the
brain and the head works and everything
else and he when he shook his head when
he was like he did this weird eerie
shake it was so it was just eerie it was
just it was cringing I just
it's like you gotta stop this did
anybody he'll die in did him yeah but
that's what he says let me die in it
anybody else have audio issues with
their pay-per-view I didn't I remember
that part audio issues I don't know yeah
I said I heard one or two bit oh you
know it was driving me nuts I've gotta
mention some below-the-belt what's
driving me [ __ ] nuts was the vh1
pop-up video tweet oh my god now hey man
is a [ __ ] hey what the fine no man and
then you could tell fighters just doing
it to get on TV oh damn this fight it's
crazy damn these these bros are throwing
has checked the only way I paid money
for this the only one I loved was no
comment by cab even that was the only
one I don't see any of it do ya leave
the social mean off my [ __ ] I agree I
agree
give me the fight by the way how grouse
did you know how amateur that looked at
these huge fights and blinked boy these
boys are throw yeah just these general
random comment right now get the [ __ ]
out of here right now but what was
really cool is hearing the impact like
because the crowd was the best was the
father's listening at DC and his
coaching was what was what now fighters
could hear DC critiquing like Oh Greg
Carr could hear it Greg Cardenas throw
light cake sir he should yet and they
would pick it up and damn it's how good
DC is as a commentator yeah of course
the best of course I'm listening the
[ __ ] BC when I can but I I I'm very
intrigued at the just engage he khabib
great fight because I think could be
painful he's got his hands full
I mean hands full as long as he doesn't
try to stand and bang with Justin
because I think he's gonna have to at
some point just like with tongue you you
I don't know how you feel about this
that the fight I'd love to see actually
love to see is Conor McGregor just
engaging because I think actually I
think Conor beat them well I think
Connors are better again overall better
striker in that more precise more
calculated I don't know if his leg kicks
are as good as Justin's Justin would
cause Justin would cause a lot of
problems for jumper for Connor out there
really to get kicked he's not that works
too good he's in and out you gotta be
stationary stationary fact if Justin
tried to go bang with I think I think
for Justin that goes Justin khabib they
want to get crazy there go Justin Connor
throwing him a payday
but looking up the look in that it's so
strange because could be poor a poor a
beat'em right I'm sorry for any beat
Justin pop or a beat Justin so it's just
about stylistically mashups are better
for certain guys it just so happens on
this god-given earth just engage a
matches a bet against Tony forcing
khabib then the rest of the division so
I was traveling is that yes he just has
to get their eggs there and then now
it's off to the races I was trying to
ask how long he's gonna hold the belt
because if he wins and then what kind of
be champ
I think Connor is a nightmare for just
engage he see I was trying to avoid this
right avoid the the temptation to jump
on the just turn full force but he's the
greatest because like you said with
styles and he's not asked in certain
style Styles it styles yeah I mean if
he's if he has to bang with Connor I
think Connors ultimately I think Connor
doesn't Bay I thought it would anything
I think Connor would have done the same
thing to tell me Ferguson probably I
think Connor would have I think I think
Connor that if that Tony showed up that
night yes I think I I don't know if
Connor hits it hard as Justin gates you
though
Johnson gate she hits very Hans knocked
out record would beg the differ you'd
say Connor hit that's true look what
color did to Nate Diaz who's a giant 170
how many times he dropped them knock him
out but who does knock out nobody no
knocks out the Diaz brothers but yeah he
knocked them down four times I'm crazy
so it's all it's all about matchups and
what the UFC wants to do but now that
now they you know they kind of have to
jam it that's assuming that's assuming
gauging it's by khabib
I'm back on the Conner Train and I got
Connor I'd never get a lot of brother I
I've got I got Connor cause if his
learning IQ his ability he does the same
thing that say who do it I'm on college
straight if he wants it and I know he's
training I'm on the Connor train
yeah no no no you throw miles at all in
the 50 oh god I keep forgetting about
him but he's yeah isn't he fighting at
70 or Aziz now you'd fight Connor at 55
man now we got some yeah they're some
[ __ ] monsters at 55 so but if boots
interesting is like how it affects you
because if Justin gets the belt then
Connors probably give me your champ by
then
2020 right or 2000 begin 2.21
but if khabib holds the belt it's tough
fight for Conor
but then Mazel it all could be don't get
back in the country that's another
question yeah yeah he will let make that
happen or you're gonna go to him or you
didn't go to fight I like a [ __ ]
fight we're gonna fly you private to
fight Island that's true just happening
it's joke this is all gonna go on all
these she's pressing it how great is it
I saw the numbers are good we don't know
the numbers but I hope they're great
horses company that runs with Hogan
no not boho no a friend that works with
the agency Tilian and Doris and now just
so you guys know that they represent the
you doesn't mean William Morris he means
telly chili lemon and George chili
indoors and Doris Jillian Doris
represent told me that it the paper you
numbers aren't great now that's just
hearsay that's like oh you haven't that
the immediate numbers that quick well
but they can see the initial surge and
see if it's somewhere well I think
adding an agency that rhymes with well
that arrives at ilium Doris is in
trouble is filing funded by bankruptcy
yes you know sometimes you make bad
calculations and a virus comes oh you
have seats 49 sold more than double
already double them what your C
experience unbelievable pacing of
pay-per-view great yeah I hope it goes
great that's what it looks like
pre-event buys oh that's good mmm-hmm
but here's that you never know you do
you it's like Disneyland we don't know
how about kissing that went pandemic
masked whatever went on the business
that we're shutting down the next year
yeah then I open - I'm 21 doing it we're
taking our bomb go home Wow Disney Walt
Disney the fellow Nazi went oh did you
shut down hold my swastika for a whole
year
what yeah they're back 2020 Tigers not
happy about it
Wow cuz if Disney opens up Tigers go you
son of a [ __ ] I'm in that's crazy man
they just shut the [ __ ] down yeah Disney
Howard selling money I guess they're set
on money the em astray there's no way
they can take a year off
Disney your thing
can take a year off what's this I'm just
reading more same thing yeah hopefully
it went well
unbelievable pacing for byes you just
never know easy rise by any of these
like Trump were you surprised by any of
the outcomes did you have Dominick Cruz
winning that fight I thought if version
of Dominick Cruz that were used to shut
up he could be so who don't can you go
to the 45 division for a second I want
to just know it what do you want I
wanted to span a size about interesting
hooter jump it up to 45 oh he's retired
well if the check is big enough he's not
retired right when he I loved what he
said so what so when he came on my show
food-truck diary watch it when we're off
here I'm going through all these
matchups here's Bubba but I'm probably
retire
hey what he was probably one more I'm
done he is I'm sick of this [ __ ] they
don't pay me enough I have other stuff
going on Wow and I think I didn't say
that's not my job but now that's all I
can talk about it
well I went really is yeah I have no
argument I was a comic sense gold
medalist 125 champ 135 champ defended
all right yeah cool dude is he too small
for Brown Ortega max Holloway those are
some beats at beat six to talk about
your family guy retired right so let's
go through Tom oh yeah he's said he's
been retired then they're not paying
money and now fight bigger guys that's
that's yeah he has trouble making 35 no
yeah he said he said it's tough it's a
it's a suit it's tiny
yeah tiny he thrives at 30 bucks you
know it's smaller he was the Adamic ruth
he you know was a weird matchup was
Hardy versus de Castro the catch was
this that was really strange I was like
what the Castro was creative and legs
and hearty softballs we got the only guy
decided left to throw a punch the last
two rounds so you broke my foot now I
get that what's wrong with your hands
though well I can't pivot I know but you
can still throw without pivoting yes
that fight was so bad well he's hard
he's not even fighting for two years
mm-hmm that's impressive
yeah now now now again destro de Castro
Castro was fighting like their school on
Monday well he could fight he could fire
you worried about being sore but there's
no school on Monday papa if you know
this when a pandemic there's no school
well sometimes believe it's possible for
them to get down at 185 mice to make 170
how about Romeo's he could easy go 205
oh yeah and DC goes it's so hard I said
I used to see cause yeah I have a
similar body but jewel fives at night
yeah I used to say that about this
depleted yeah yeah people he so thick
DC's so [ __ ] thick when he's walking
around but everyone's like you're these
guys can get down yep I guess maybe they
could the problem is they killed
themselves together until you look at
their lifestyle hips their ass is there
they're just their bone structures are
just they're so thick
that's a [ __ ] friend if you walk on
them he looks starving right there
Wow some death's door though yeah he
really is dude that's no joke
just curious is Connor up 45 got cold my
god is he gonna live here that's
horrifying
yeah he looks [ __ ] look at his face
he's all sunken in you just can't
maintain it no great fight self yeah
it's the first Saturday at like in this
quarantine everything feels like a long
drawn-out Sunday Saturday was the first
day I felt normal
I was so excited oh man and then I know
Sunday I got my last dance episode 7 & 8
I got American Idol Oh God Saturday
Sunday it was fantastic this week this
week's for me great too yeah to be a
fight companion that's kind of exciting
yeah UFC fight you know we go leave that
he looks dead oh my god he looks like
the guy from the he looks like guy from
Pirates of the Caribbean the skeleton
that tells him where to go use him as a
fact is that Pirates of the Caribbean or
as that is what is he doing there it's
just or is that a India is that it's
like he's not eating anything the way
weight cut is such a [ __ ] well movies
oh no you want movie that is huh Hellboy
type in Hellboy skeleton are we hearing
anything from comments shut you talking
about fighting shut up shut the [ __ ] up
you shut up I asked the question are we
hearing anything about Connor uh he was
talking shits and ideas
the
Dana says they want to fight on fight
Island there yes there's Connor that's
spot on
that's exactly what it is there yes he's
the back rest home we're together you're
good at tech you're good at the best
gift a gift it's the workout a pickle
what is that that one go red pickle
reference we need your time on a bike on
the bottom they're thick boy first team
right there yeah probably fight on fight
Island it's fun for them boys turn did
you see Tony's Tony Ferguson's dance on
his Renton yeah hot spot yeah yeah to
that 90s that early 90s our music didn't
rat or sound yet working below the belt
yeah now he's still in the hospital I
take it after what I orbital and they're
probably scans and stuff that was a
rough one dude that's his girl such a
stud he's just a different dude he's a
very special human being man mm-hmm
he really is he's a special [ __ ]
human being one of the best yeah I know
it's a fight game I just love to watch I
[ __ ] hate seeing that I do agree with
you I think it I think if I was his
corner I would throw the towel I would
have I would have looked at his face and
I would've been like I don't like this
it's not where the style is not a
knockout artist and there was no sign
there's gonna not get you out really so
it's like what are we doing dude yeah
live to fight another day
so hard would have been really upset but
I think weeks later like probably the
best yeah so hard to do it in his corner
though when you're dealing with a
warrior like that I mean it's like y'all
have corners I guess fire he might fire
you I mean that's fine you're protecting
herself for the longevity yeah yeah that
was a great uppercut right there yeah I
figured out my tattoo at least hmm oh
dude hey old [ __ ]
the old [ __ ] I'm getting those feathers
yeah hey old [ __ ] listen this why I was
today at 3 p.m. I was gonna get a the
the rattlesnake logo the fake boy look
on my ass why because when I'm riding
can see it so you know it's the thick
boy I'm so sick of all the people on
thick boy on the trails so I want to
start your own company the hanging on
the trail story not gonna share your own
company yeah yeah I should get one
terrible visitor well so but I was
getting you the snake on my quad on my
thigh right today at 3 p.m. and then oh
you're not though because your tattoo is
gonna be indicted for murder so and I
text them when we get this show it hey
man wait i assuming we're not on for 3
p.m.
why is my tattoo arts the dime piece on
the left we were just talking about him
a couple weeks ago yeah I got a tattoo
if you go to his Instagram and the last
[ __ ] guy you got a tattoo it go to
his Instagram yeah but it should be
manslaughter because I was talking to
Jay - between Jacobs if he just gets a
good lawyer it's gonna be a manslaughter
price they'll do some time there I am
there I am there I am now he has a
mclaren 570s 7 20s but regardless he was
drinking drinking with fellow youtuber
and they ran into a tree I know he broke
his hip he was drinking so he was very
drunk when he got in the car we don't
know you just can't do that yeah but you
can't you shouldn't go to Pritchard you
go to prison it's in you it's it's
manslaughter Eric can be murder you can
go to jail for murder
yes but be if word let's say and I don't
know how it works but it doesn't seem
right to me say you and I both get drunk
I'll find the kid I know Brian and you
go hey dude let's go let's go to the gym
you drive to the gym and I Drive and I
wreck and you die just your heart like
what I'm doing real fast you die crash
and you die killed and then I survive
how I'm flourishing do I get hey she's
heading this up do I go to prison for
murder you're insulting me while I get
in for murder even though we both agreed
weights that so give me some we're both
intoxicated your brother go hey Brennan
can you drop me off from wiha get some
work to do I know sure dude and so we
drive - WeHo and yeah like all exciting
yeah you got this abrasion bones why
would I have a boner I don't use doing
working on your dick I know you're we
hope okay so I'm jacking it you jack you
will kind of you just like how much
money you made murder yeah you like I
can't wait to get in there I'm like all
right dude I'm just gonna drop you up
please don't ejaculate
okay so we're driving but we're both
drunk we've both agreed to jump in the
vehicle yeah I crash on our way to we
home even though we're both under
consent it's not manslaughter it there
are people doing life right now for
getting into a car being drunk and
killing somebody in another car or
something no different different we
didn't we didn't hit a bystander you we
both agree begin this vehicle
intoxicated so so you can now if you
kidnap them I understand that it feels
like you're gonna car jump out you might
crash you die you can absolutely be
indicted for murder and convicted it's
just like this if you if you do a crime
with someone the kind of person the
person who gets you the car the car the
guy steals the car and then even if he's
not in the car and you go off and kill
somebody that guess I'm interim you can
be indicted for murder too so you're all
part of a murder conspiracy you're all
part of the murder right so there have
been people that you know get complete
healthfully news is you can do for
manslaughter 10:00 a.m. at 6 to 11 years
hold on probation with up to 1 year or 3
or 6 or 11 so if you can get
manslaughter and he got pretty fake he
could do 15 years pretty face now here's
tip for this he doing 15 years
guaranteed under 15 I don't know if
intoxicated I bet you he gets I bet you
get the year with a really good lawyer I
guess it depends on what he said to the
cops it depends on how was broken it and
they did it but they did a blood alcohol
test on the tragic of all this the 25
year old that dialogue that's that's a
huge crash is horrible 25 year old kid
no and you know what they're doing
they're drinking like a couple of idiots
they did a very dumb thing and sometimes
it turns out that's why does I never
ever drink and drive just you can't do
it and and everybody has done it
everybody has driven buzzed once in
their life or 10 times in their
or 40 or 40 and every time you do that
you're taking someone else's now have I
seen it's out now Daniel the prison
system special a little harsh
you're not fighter your pretty boy you
just seen the movie get hard it's an
issue I can be you're Kevin Hart it's
nice I can be 7r I can show you the way
could use you in there he could use the
question is he's half Brazilian yes the
question is why sidered white or is he
considered oh you're fully nation no
you're full internation yeah yeah you
just lie like any background I'll tell
you what it's a nightmare on so many
levels for him I'm sure he's not a bad
guy
he killed his friend he's nice he's dude
first of all I think he's twenty three
or twenty he's a young kid that started
business in San Francisco wanted more
for his life so he came to LA became one
the biggest tattoo artist of so when he
goes to jail he's gonna be doing tattoos
you know that he'll be doing everybody's
tattoo jailhouse tattoo he'll be fine
yeah he'll be fine but I mean not fine
because he he killed his friend which is
a disease which he has to live with for
the rest of his life man I'm sorry about
that all the way around stupid [ __ ]
snake tattoo on your thigh which I you
know sighs you'd do things like that and
I go like this I go it's like when Chris
was in his car and he had cold
sunglasses on I love that and he had his
card he was a head cold sunglasses and
some and like a necklace and I was like
like in some ways can't believe I'm
friends with any great and he threw the
glass to where I go you have those
glasses and this car he could roast me
all day I won't change yeah you're just
that guy yep
it still lays at that - it's just not
gonna be from him I'm not going to
prison I'm looking to get a rattlesnake
yeah you've never seen our official logo
chantry's guy hash bring that up
I think I sold 700 hoodies with a snake
on it yes 707 is that good I don't I
don't know I don't know that's how long
I don't know numbers you're making me so
mad though you've changed a lot since
you come up that low girl and sit sit
boy in her knees ride hard drive thick
there's some 100 good I don't know
you're making me mad all right you're
becoming in you bothering me
I've heard the p-diddy a podcast I don't
know hey have you said I didn't say that
it I didn't say laddie that [ __ ] man I
gotta come up with a [ __ ] company hey
dude
imma let you in will you fold shirts I'm
not folding inserts a piece of [ __ ] too
busy I got three TV shows believe it or
not and that's the other problem I
should worry about my TV shows I
shouldn't be worried about this I do
want to start my own [ __ ] money
companies still know what no I came to
you with nothing the big lie alright
bill said all day
be on time thing about you dancing all
dance somewhere man honey still enjoy
yeah I got to come up with a company hey
are there any entrepreneurs out there
that want to start a company with me oh
this is like the Rick and Morty though
you want to start an app you want to
start an app and he starts an app he
creates a love love up and takes over
the world you want to start an app I
love app would be good what's your type
and you plug it in dude how about a dude
just spitballing ideas here how about a
old person's love app it's called drinks
it's called wrinkles ranks isn't just my
older like milk you know some people
call me now I'm on my comments Gary hey
tarts sweet sweeter now I'll get eight
tarts
hey man tarts and rinks do but how about
how about a love app called rinks or
wrinkles I like wrinkles I like the
rinks is good I got to make some
t-shirts for rinks sure whatever it is
so hundred here's the thing hey so we'll
do wrinkles it's just old people looking
for love it's a good idea dude wrinkles
wrinkles
where'd you met wrinkles wearing diapers
don't you mean battles then recept that
just unbelievable male fun there with
their wrinkles yeah
or dude here's nothing wrinkles I think
it's got to be something good like
wrinkles and honey no no what we call it
honey rings but how about this it's ring
kits it's called wrinkles and we hook up
old people with sugar babies that's ever
really a good idea it's basically riot
but just for old people it's a really
good idea they're not good you don't
have to be famous just I'd be old silver
singles oh well there goes my dad
[ __ ] silver singles and their charge
wrinkles wrinkles singles wrinkles
little dingle wrinkles in singles
singles
oh no here's this singles with wrinkles
is you that shingles singles with
wrinkles with shingles now that's good
how about this dude how about this Six
Feet Under got problems with your Six
Feet Under and then you like swipe right
on old Pete skeletons no rattle eighty
days laughing goes what who's into it no
singles with wrinkles I just came up
with my amazing company singles with
wrinkles singles with rank on screen app
got problems with that with your
digestion pissing more than normal where
your [ __ ] 30% off Botox October only
ah yeah at balls hang low but we have
positive value having issues with
incontinence gray pubes were your your
socks bunch up around your socks or your
ankles are skinny that's good dude why
would my ankles be skinny you know
people they're all lose all the hair
down there you ever notice how oh people
old men have no hair on their [ __ ] but
I do on there like a good circulation
yeah they lose their hair no really most
guys who are starting started at like 45
but I do
oh the hairless cats hairless cats your
room here let's cat hairless cats look
at those ankles oh yeah if you don't
work out yeah see you see you see the
old both varicose lens all old people
saw it scrunch up like dogs it's like
you're seeing a dog's feet they're all
wrinkly at the bottom tell old people's
feet are it's pretty cool probably right
that's good I'll check out the ass on
other three knees your body breaks down
time as a [ __ ] Papa took this
bill yesterday dude yeah well they're
one day meeting you gotta be careful
Bruce these [ __ ] ravines on my target
suck and I flip over it gotta be careful
man
annoying who it hurt really - observing
her I'm gonna start elbow pad line it I
need bigger gloves my palms are thick
dude these dick beaters are thick you
guys my fingers come on I can't fit over
my tits not true
yeah my fingers fit yeah you have like
large you have irregular fingers but you
ever think
dick dick beaters yeah these things have
taken a punishment dude yeah you got
Tallis two strong hands strong hands not
lifting it all just biking just biking
losing weight two hours a day yep two
and a half yesterday I did let's see 24
do you forget in 32 miles if you eat
beforehand 32 miles Springs do you live
before no fast here's the problem with
fasting though so I used to go around 8
a.m. so I'm back home around 10:30 11:00
and I do a shake and I don't eat a real
meal to about 2:00 or 3:00 yesterday
drove to a location right was like oh
this trails too [ __ ] easy this a
waste of my time dude like seven or
eight miles it's like I'm [ __ ] out of
here got back in the car one of my
regular trail but time we got on the Reg
trails 10:30 now I'm out there for
20-something miles 24 miles on the
regular trip second week I'm shaky Papa
got lightheaded yeah so I took one of
those gel packs huh and then [ __ ] hit
the road yeah that'll get the road I'll
get to you I listen to it oh you want to
come with me San Diego chapter Thursday
rescheduled Thursday nothing I got the
kids can't do can't you reschedule no
can you trade off ah let me see Amanda's
sugar bear can't you trade off let me
see what Amanda sugar bear here can't
you trade off to Friday let me see what
I can do let me see what I can do do you
be able to read as Santa Cruz heckler
ebike so your old stupid legs don't have
to do much yeah get up the mountain I
have nice legs that's the heck you have
good legs probably good for biking I
heard you get on a bike let's do a
heckler a heckler with the power yeah
light and your mics you'd rock that I'll
do that and then one girl that had Santa
Cruz headquarters my boys didn't take us
there papa might begin a new bike as
well well I've been getting on my
[ __ ] I'm getting on my cruiser oh
yeah that's a gay hey that's a nice bike
dude but him not that that that yellow
jacket yellow too much even for me the
black now that's an electric bike that's
an electric bike that's the electric
bike we're gonna be riding Wow Sam are
you right I went to young Ryan went to
oh nice
on the San Diego trails that might be
badass the San Diego Chapter is just I'm
saying dude okay and so you make me
about the chapter stuff but this I'm
sorry yeah you see one okay chapter go
nuts no I didn't see that I see that did
you see the South African chapter going
man there's a lot of like countries huh
worldwide movement dude I wonder if
there any [ __ ] I wonder how the thin
boy chapters are doing I got a check I
don't know if they're thriving with
their there's how about cash sent in a
group message you're not on a big deal
can't send a group text of her mom for
Mother's Day I'm looking on the liking
cat Kathy I was lucky a straight up
let's take a lower fence smoke show
really yes yeah cuz I posted up a photo
from when I was a kid my mom was like 23
she just had me yeah I think the white
tank-top just hot as [ __ ] yeah her mom
is I was like Kat is that your mind off
his chance mama cats mom no I just yeah
that's not a weekly read dad huh no my
dad has always had a rat tail a lot of
people say that he has the same haircut
as Theo oh but does he is it a size loss
just not as thick in the back where it's
long so he has like a rat tail whereas
Bo has like a full mole mole it might be
a wig we don't know we don't know but
your dad's are the real thing all
natural all right always if cats mom is
a bonafide smoke show I need to see a
picture no that's right little cat oh
yeah I'm the one in pink mom is cute
right oh jeez yeah that's my mom at my
age what 24 I hope we got you you work
at baby how old are you then I think I'm
about like a year I'm under here under
yo strawberry in your hand I think so
I'm oh I was always eating so I would
have man who's Dora the Explorer in the
back that's my cousin Marcia she she
hates that photo every time I
after croffer Allen has it okay I love
cute little girl dude your mom is
freaking gorgeous I mean dude you don't
have a rat ton that pull hose you know
I'm saying so your rat tail and you own
it you gettin hose yeah my dad is
actually 15 years older than my mom - we
how was he dead that looks like you
years older than you 50 he's in his like
me seventies looks like he knows how to
knows his way around a rain stick I'll
put it that way we've done nothing tor
has ever been said lately is the most
wisdom around the brain Stig's now
forever
your mom's FEMA bona fide dime piece you
know my mom's hot oh yeah oh yeah
absolutely but Papa
looks like he's thick is he thick he
could be no not thick I don't know
there's like you can't be in a club that
you're not in and say people are in it
well here's the thing you're not I don't
you don't know the require why is your
club so describe Tori what if you are a
thin boy well you're thinking you're
sick at heart you're in you but you're
not thinking hard why don't you have a
thin boy offshoot like a branch out
why not it's not what we do do we don't
specialize in that but I feel like there
would be guys who know what we'll see
how you do on the trails on Thursday you
might get in maybe maybe I start maybe
you could let me take over the thin boy
chapter you're really pushing the
chapter I did you like it see I feel
like it's a good sell why can't your
gonna have thick boy and then you why
wouldn't you have thin boy Justin boy
that's not fun it's like what then we're
focused our own Club well I'm your
memberships predicated on how you do on
Thursday so ditch the key I gotta get
myself [ __ ] calling ditch the kids
and don't do legs before you'll be now
toast I'll be I'll be in some trouble
how far are we going be out for a couple
hours do two hours two hours on the
trails be good for it yeah be so fun
wake up morning we'll cruise down there
don't touch the car we'll cruise down
there fiddle fiddle with your dials and
gears we takin that Porsche yep daily
driver really you can drive fast the
factory will be bright dress ready dress
have you been pulled over in that thing
nope never nope other cars look I got
one thing to say and that's draftkings
you want to make some money dude USCG 49
if you didn't wet your whistle maybe
you're watching like dude I want to
watch the fights make money cool draft
kings.com Bubba baby bear one-day
fantasy sports is putting you in the
center of the action
two million dollars in total prizes up
for grabs and fantasy MMA this week you
can bet on weds II bet on Saturday huh
it's good stuff you haven't tried to get
fancy I'm amazed easy to play too
you pick six fighters stay under the
salary cap and pilot points for advances
takedowns and a lot more there's no
better way to put your mmm and knowledge
to the test and it compete for your
Sheriff over two million dollars in
total prizes with draftkings
yes download the draftkings app now and
use the promo code fighter when you sign
up for your shot at over two million
dollars to 2 million million $2 dollars
Wow I'm told it easy that's over 2
million dollars and told prizes up for
grabs this week so sign up now with the
promo code fighter to get started only
at draftkings eligibility restrictions
apply see drafting song hum for details
Mother's Day house you guys Mother's Day
it was good I just FaceTime my mom all
day oh yeah how's she doing she's doing
good and then I watch Vikings for the
rest of the night who you been you
finish it
I know I'm on season 2 right now I've
been doing nothing but watching like
Viking shows you like Vikings that's the
thing I'm I'm into right now pretty
barbaric yeah it's dope yeah I don't
have any show right now I've the last
dancers is so good but other than that I
have nothing
Rick and Marty but I'll have like a
Shawn really ante right I've finished
everything yeah I will I watched Steve
JA
I watched the jobs movie with Ashton
Kutcher top five for me don't at me it's
my favorite movie Jim would you house
your mother's day is good I didn't see
my mom but I just gave her money I just
filled her Amazon account with extra
money that's nice
she spent a lot of money on Amazon she
doesn't that's why I want it just to buy
whatever she wants guys like necessities
see I should invest in AMC Theaters cuz
Amazon's about to buy it nothing else
hmm
you wanna see my mom sure she looked
like death no and there's a bad picture
but then I can I just picture up for a
reason
dude my mom my mom is the best mom in
the world
everyone says then huh that's why I
think you know one who loves their mom
as much as I do thinks the same thing up
there you go but she won't see this
because she has no idea what Instagram
is that being said I posted this pic so
you could see the package I've been
working with since don't say package all
right well look at that package man you
saw no one on the yellow oh that's
that's a good package damn package is
who's close who's tall in your family
just me
why are you six four yeah it's weird
yeah you're big and your brother is your
brother be he's 511 so nice yes thank
you your brother yeah what's that she's
making your parents my dad is probably
five nine five eight you giant Korean
yeah yes I'm a weird uh nomally you ever
been singing like you know what's going
to get a girlfriend stop singing you're
one of those guys know the girls stop
doing what you enjoy
I just got start seeing again I just I
see that you're not longer wearing your
mask yeah remember the video not the
Friday when the we sort of opened up to
the phase I was like all right okay
that's ready hmm no I do with us making
funny right no how long until is there
any word on when we don't have to wear
masks we were talking to just talking
about that we don't know I just
remembered that they had a announcement
saying that on May 15th something was
supposed to be lifted or yeah like we're
reassessing our situation here
in California to see whether or not we
can open certain places up I don't know
what every day what day is it today is
the 11th you're some sort on the 15th
yeah but I don't know what set to happen
all I'm saying
phase 3 became clown newsome's looks 6/4
handsome Spanish you speak Spanish - yup
fluent he does yep being it just is how
do you can terrible
I don't [ __ ] know I think he's a
blizzard stage - nonsense of toy stores
bars no we'll open up soon as they open
up Tiger gonna go you son of a [ __ ] hum
there he's gonna go retail business
curbside pickup blame
Stage three here salons they're open now
nail salons gyms movie theaters sport
events with live audience Flores said
hold my bear impersonal religious
services Stage four that's where we want
to get guys sporting events with
audience convention centers concert
venues that's what we need what stage
are we in now stage to one Russia three
point five right now it's sort of like
stage 1.5 we're not even that stage to
you this is the tux on ABC seven if you
watch that Jesus Christ
I just think shot up let's to just you
like bring this up like they want other
in the dick your attendances go we are
but CNN was I just want like what I'm
just curious but CNN was saying this is
like a 9/11 every single day and we're
acting like snow God but he never once
mentioned that fee mean age is still 81
years old and he's using these stats
that don't necessarily play out so I
just I I just find it curious that they
never ever bring that up well I hear
about I've heard about a Sweden no it's
good talk about them have you heard
about how I mean George are doing have
you heard about that
no no he's doing great yeah Oh in
strange weird you don't hear about the
mean well I know that we're you and I
are gonna be in [ __ ] Houston May 20
well that's official I'm going with
Brian we're doing shows in use May 29 30
31
Houston get your tickets tickets are
going on sale today
I guess I got a cool picture for Martin
- yeah so we're gonna be there me and
Brendan shop at J shop doing some
stand-up mm thanks getting back at it
Thank You Texas Thank You Houston little
say thanks yet let's see if anybody
shows up well that is an issue but I
think from what I understand people are
clamoring to get back to the clubs
that's what I've heard from the club's
themselves people want to they want to
go out they won't laugh of course Club
say no but they do they do
I'm excited
do you fly me spare time a pissing
around yeah look at that
it's cheap a lot of bucks my needs for
sighs you know this yeah well you know
not stop as a thousand dollars no first
class what you can spare fit 60 bucks
hey Mary hell they even get 60 bucks
dude Delta 90 bucks what the [ __ ] -
Houston direct fly you're gonna be gonna
book your own flights or should we have
J do not find the kid to pick out they
do it yeah I guess you get out of this
huh you get it well I find kid to us
since we're both going would you know
what yes I'm out do you want to go first
I am talking out loud come on down chin
come on to film it welcome to come if no
one shows up we're not gonna release in
any videos just the staff in the mask
thanks coming guys man it's good to be
here in Houston
who's your beer meeting I think we can
get 250 people in the room I think
something like push oh yeah this is a
big market yeah big market it's gonna be
hot gonna be hot the weather isn't
Houston I like your eye I like it up
yeah muy caliente restaurant opening -
right I've no idea
Houston weather
Houston Texas weather maybe - not to buy
right now I bet I found it ollie
not bad at all high of 86 it's hotter
and hotter in the valley dude hey he's
nicer [ __ ] the holiday
my god that's not bad Houston is how far
away from Austin pretty far two hours I
think three hours okay
I'd say four right Jen I'll look right
now try it you talk about driving right
yeah San Antonio's the ones close to
Austin yes yes
I never mind then let's do some current
events it is a two hour and 30 minute
drive from Austin not too bad but not
fun just not not not close enough to go
to Austin you and I got Austin to like
see I'm reading the guys to farm though
absolutely give me a better way okay so
the other day Kourtney Kardashian went
on to Instagram and she posted up a
video of the front of her house that got
TPD by her sister Chloe and her son
Mason they were just playing a prank on
her decide to TP the front of the house
they were having fun with this prank and
when the internet saw it they were
really angry with the fact that Khloe
Kardashian thought it was okay to waste
toilet paper during this time guide
Twitter that's a lot of toilet paper
though so she just TP her house and
people are mad that they're wasting the
toilet paper yeah there's so much more
to worry about
yeah alrighty okay you guys were talking
about this earlier but shanghaied
Shanghai's Disneyland is actually
reopening today and they changed their
capacity to 80,000 people to to 24,000
people how much fun that's gonna be it's
gonna be so much I'm so much better I
wish LA would do that
do you like the real strict VIP pass
they were thinking about that before the
pandemic hit because people there were
just too many people coming in and out
busy man and so they were thinking that
they would sell tickets ahead of time
and just hit a certain number of
capacity doesn't exist have not
announced when yes Dean parks will open
however Disney really confirmed Disney
springs at Walt Disney World begin to
reopen its restaurants and retail stores
may 20th that's in Florida though yeah
any Disneyland the original yeah we do
okay so Takashi 6:9 has been released
from prison and the other day he posted
up this photo he is currently on house
arrest I believe or like he's supposed
to be staying inside so was being hiding
yeah in hiding and he ended up taking
this photo out on his balcony a neighbor
saw him take this photo and released
where he was so he had to move what the
neighbor do that we have no idea doesn't
like him super dangerous you know what's
interesting is you wanna Instagram live
get 5 million views
I'm record for views yep now the the oh
geez of the rap game are like dude I
don't know why the young audience and
young viewers are celebrating him being
a rat like you guys have it all twisted
yes you know it's ridiculous now your
boys gonna squeal like a canary if I was
in his shoes as well sure but here's
what he did he ended up flying I mean he
ended up like turning in some all the
Bloods the table top blood yeah only
date and then they were like you're
willing to put you in witness protection
and then I'll handle it myself
you know scarin Gus cool do that well
it's not like he's hard to find their
spot but he does have rainbow here any
tattoos um yeah I mean alright
he has kids and stuff too so I don't
know man it's harder to kill somebody
who's high-profile with all the cameras
in the world but I don't know yeah guys
that do it they got guys what we got
guys they got guys they got guys yeah
put away the the leaders yeah they have
connections to lots of big I gotta would
imagine it would not want to be him
scary men it's not like they forget like
10 years from now you're never good
you're never gonna be good yes stressful
that is now you get your freedom yeah
which is worth I'd rather have that than
being prison but [ __ ] dude just song I
divide live stream I rat it
Wow yeah it's out stop pushing this
right
tricky right yeah it's tricky what else
get quick sad one Ben still was dead
passed away man he was amazing on King
of Queens and Seinfeld he was great in a
heartbreak kid man so funny well he was
so fun he was just a great guy time
whose whole area yeah I spend time with
him yeah when I was I did the
storytellers thing Ben was there and in
[ __ ] Nantucket and yeah I [ __ ]
made him I was so instant cuz I got up
to tell we had to tell stories and Ben
Stiller and his dad and his mom were in
the [ __ ] audience and I was sitting
kind of next to him right behind him and
I think that still were behind him you
said the other night I was right next to
because it was all I was like I was
you're behind you said well it was like
now we were in a group kind of sing in a
group it was like it wasn't like rows of
tears it was all chairs like it was just
chairs right no sir and then um but I
had to get him tell story I was nervous
I never get nervous if I was a little
nervous at first because you know it was
like every huge [ __ ] star it was you
know but I got him told this really
funny story and then I I ended up
talking to him for a while but he still
is a legend man he was such a good guy
dude and he was chose to he put him in
all the movies Susan - no he's he's
great he's the reason I became an actor
I mean the guy's a Hall of Famer he's
been acting for forever how old was he
82 if the guy from natural cause you
what a bummer
what a stud is it a bummer though he had
a good run 82 I think 82 or 92 lemon
either way it had a great run her life
nobody to celebrate his life great run
he does 92 92 is a hell of a run he
looks so good for 92
what a run oh my god he was so funny man
mm-hmm
married for 62 years she was always on
the shows - oh she was [ __ ] hilarious
listen she says she says she's a great
actor in her own right Ben Stiller's a
[ __ ] you there
imagine a holdfast so funny all [ __ ]
families great yeah just this weekend
that they had all like probably because
they knew this because meet the parents
was on Heartbreak Kid was on oh yeah all
the movies the dad was in check out
younger that's cool man
he was just funny all right check this
out I just saw this Mike Tyson dude
take a look you know who's holding this
for my yep when we get his podcast
[Music]
creepy huh that is frightening Jesus
Christ King it was gonna fight that you
lose that way well he's my age
damn um when we met him we do his
podcast Morales lolis mother he had just
had an operation right no he was on
medication
where he took all these pills I was so
worried I was like what's wrong with him
barely walk took these pills he'd barely
move but he's a common operation wasn't
he the worst podcast of all time yeah it
was from an operation no no I sighs his
handler his guy he's like I you took
this medication he brought before the
party yeah he's like cuz he's out of it
when he takes it hopefully you don't
have to have any more also I said his
company you know he's he doesn't need
the money
hey I didn't know his 20 million but Jay
sent me said we've been getting a bunch
of emails people saying his net worth is
3 million so 20 million you definitely
yeah but uh cuz he said he owned all
that we but he just has a percentage of
it yeah named after him too though
mm-hmm oh well yeah I wonder is he
actually came out fighting yeah charity
that's why he's doing it charity for
charity for charity he wants a
legitimate a pony too so he's not gonna
dad bare-knuckle thing like Shannon no
context grants that's all fake
he looks good he looks scary I mean you
want to hear this story
yes so this woman who does nails for
people this is during the lockdown too
so she went to go visit one of her
clients she showed up with a glass of
wine and acted a little weird and then
for some reason she got next to this
alligator that was by the lake she
wanted to touch it all right can't do
that you can't do that and then finally
they're like no it took a deer last time
she's like well I don't look like a deer
so she gets near it it grabs her leg
and as it's pulling her into the water
she goes well I guess I'm not gonna do
that anymore or somebody in a very calm
voice sure and she died of course and
the alligator pulled her into the water
yes
and then here tried to pull her from the
water the Elias started to roll and
covert lost her grip on the rope plus
until police that'll get took underwater
and she released the rope when the
sheriff's deputies in the fire
department arrived they saw no movement
on the pond 10 to 15 minutes later
coverts body surface the alligator
pulled her back underwater but
resurfaced a few months later the
officer was able to shoot it place
received the body was just here was the
left leg oh did you shoot the alligator
that's a yeah every tear trade the body
that's silly Cobert was the third person
killed by an alligator in South Carolina
in the past four years it's just
attacked South Carolina had never
recorded a person killed by an alligator
if it was the same [ __ ] alligator you
kind of have to kill it I won't do this
again
you know collar boys giant dragons
they're dinosaurs dude it's like you got
all drunk and want to pet the dinosaurs
station why not to go away it seems like
it that yeah there's like something was
up with her I don't look like it there
it was like what Wow being pulled into
the water and being calm about it well
and you're not and that day I mean what
do you have you're doing nothing I guess
you're just getting pulled in you're not
pulling yourself you can't go like this
cuz that doesn't matter this in the dirt
and the women
waters now the hardest biting animal I
think is the North American alligator
that's such a bummer it also that's deer
doing deer [ __ ] I mean exports exports
also dares though yeah this person tells
the story about that guy he knew who
said I'm going to take a piss and the
guy in Florida guy goes careful cuz it
was behind a bar and he goes cuz that
that that drainage ditch has an
alligator and the key gets [ __ ] that
alligator dinner song so well you guys
what do we have here what have we here
well hello drunk man flex a little off
that's cool even if they're a full board
wouldn't matter doesn't matter
and they're off uh looks like Graham
little appetizer tonight dogs dogs
disappear all the time
GCS dogs in Africa barking I don't
watching it is it new it's it wasn't
it's it's kind of new by the video let
me take your picture two dogs are
barking in the outlet you just see the
crocodile and you're like please get out
of the ylm see that and she was like
[ __ ]
well it's a crocodile
that's Christ
that's right pull up the salt waters
where's the croc I was coming daddy mom
oh right so sad oh right
[Applause]
Nach Ayoka boy my job but good morning
were those his dogs I don't know I don't
think so he said that surface was
slippery yeah he feels good you could
see the fear in the dog now there's
another one where the dog is just
barking and you just see the [ __ ] me
like that crocodiles are just they will
eat
they [ __ ] what is that it's a [ __ ]
dinosaur dude you don't hang around
dinosaurs don't have no was I slapping
the crocodiles in Costa Rica yes I would
I wish you hadn't you told me to stop
doing it I did what they told me they're
already fed and they're pretty less so I
still are not do real help big that one
yes I was slapping until they're not I
know you were like leaning out all
casual a little drunk drag you were
actually dragging a lazy hand across AK
don't feed me dreams like put it around
I said oh look at it spin look at its
bumps I don't take it that that let's
grab another of the spices like grabbing
the spike like a stick-shift
croc better yeah croc better great I'm
gonna start my company called croc
better look at this now pet dog was
there's another one right why are people
and their dogs do this I don't know the
guy whew we don't see it so bad uh-oh
that looks like a husky oh he's really
the Huskies fighting got a dog what is
that see the
that that would be a crocodile grabbing
the husky and then we call it the Gator
roll and so then he's rolling to break
all the bones and then put him in the
water I'm just gonna store yeah so you
so you get all molded and algae built
there it is that's the one right this is
the one yeah this is such a bummer cause
she's watching these [ __ ] great dogs
and you can just see it's like dogs
don't know they just sorry it was the a
dog you don't see the [ __ ] Crocs
that's the problem
they just sit see ambush predators just
like that just like that
least that one was quick another one's
always quick but [ __ ] man yeah but you
see the German Shepherds this way see
the German Shepherd going yeah by those
dinosaurs yeah
hey Brian you're back here you're right
it might be dinosaurs my daughter yeah
yeah my dog would have come right for it
any no way yeah
they don't know they go after snakes
they just you got to keep you gotta have
you got to keep your dog on up dude
that's like people on these trails he's
on the trail large rattlesnake yeah
every time and I see people walking the
dogs off leash and let him go behind
your dog that's where all the routes
links arm like God says the dogs died
from a bum snake bite all you know why
they bound the nose my daughter my ID to
carry my dog had to carry my dogs a bit
to the vet
the dogs just to or their kids I'm like
you have no idea what monsters are in
those [ __ ] all gasp I see him every
day lady I was in Florida and the dude
said he was a kite surfing and he said
he was - France he was there are
monsters I see monsters all the time
always much love yeah no no I sharks
bull sharks Oh
there are dark monsters like for me when
I fell off my boat I get on there you
know I was like oh yeah
cuz I was like gonna dip I don't play
those games I don't even play this game
what's this shark attack yeah new new
we're at Santa Cruz oh that's a great
white they don't know what it was yet
but we know I know it's like when
there's a serial killer on the loose and
like woman's head taken
body worn as a suit like we know that
was a serial killer though we know this
is a guy I love when they go east close
it for a one-mile stretch for five days
mmm will you that shirt collected
pictures of shark well that's a great
water is not sure yeah yeah I don't
think it's worth it he spotted 15 great
whites while boning there there's a
rally on the desert island said he
spotted 15 great whites
great white swimming near the shore yeah
and people still surf because I did it
and Omar did it bite him then he went to
shore and died
let's find out did they find him
I don't think they actually felt worse
when they don't find you yeah
and the people like well we're still
looking was surfing Santa Cruz Monday
when the attack card that's for what
type of shark all the time all the time
he's the best 17 year old California you
know general in the nation
yes he's number 200 in the nation yes
and the hundred and other 199 are from
Hawaii and he goes you ain't [ __ ] and if
you can't surf Hawaii Hawaii is he's not
[ __ ] it's you're not [ __ ] unless you
can serve Hawaii it's like it's adorable
that you can serve that's two it's 26
years old what a [ __ ] that's terrible
mm you gotta win this Shark Week August
Wow first fatality in 16 years that's
that's how rare it is doctor 100 miles
under George I think it's all hundred
yards okay that's not that far out
lifeguard flood down he was able to get
on shore okay he must have been bit so
bad probably took his leg huh
maybe it's body and they bite you them
you know right in the side of it not fun
you're gonna go though it's pretty brave
yeah what a bummer
damn it Tim it seems like it Brendan
what would you do if a shark attack you
if you fight it using your technique
there's nothing you can do is that the
sharks with their the the dogs of the
alligators Jesus so quick yes and no if
you got it by the way yes they're no
they're like sitting out there taunting
the [ __ ] I'll give a year's like hey
man all right this what you want to do
yeah well we're gonna bite your face off
yeah if they're my dogs like bring it
they're made for it they're just so mate
look you have no chance you're in the
water dog yeah but you don't kill the
alligators no oh you're disgusted I was
doing alligator no you don't not for
killing a dog that's or human or the
human dad to do it to get the body cuz
they do alligator was grabbing the body
who's gonna take it out down again you
got it and it's gonna take someone human
it's far gonna take more that's true
once you got a taste yeah they say that
about like big cats was that
that sweet sweet sweet blood we got go
and see all of tigers away this is much
better than the deer easier to kill them
my dear
yeah a little more fat than the deer
Siegfried and Roy Roy has passed away
from they say complications from the
corona virus didn't happen you do they
got bin the neck by [ __ ] tiger you
survived that though I watch a
documentary on them gay boys this is
this I don't know if they were gay
oh no they were they talked about it
they used to date Yeah right they used
to date and then they just decided be
business partners and not date and that
one was like yeah well dude I'm gonna
bite your [ __ ] you know that
damn that's a shame to see that you're a
little bit it's a little bit of a weird
video I just watched a little odd all
right I I just need to I need to retire
now I can't because I'm gonna be home
what if this is he he's English it's for
England really why is it something an ox
I don't know I don't know I don't know
what's - hey why do you do that on
muscle to eyes you know man how old is
he's probably very very old I think in
his 90s right no price seventy somebody
might be in his age you know retire I
got a I got a come over the company and
I gotta sell it and I gotta stop doing
everything like Jerry's 89 boy he's so
good in science the lens look how old he
looks in this picture but in the video
he looked younger
yeah 82 Sean Connery is still alive any
night what about us you should've
retired yeah so did Gene Hackman you got
a retire I look forward to retiring do
you really yeah
I can't imagine you wanting to retire
what you do what you can do don't save
right you tell me where you riding it
one more time I'm gonna freak the [ __ ]
down people that write don't say that
write all of that what are you gonna do
I wish you'd be bored incredibly bored
and another animal tag you have this is
just fun [ __ ] yeah it's a big goose with
black feet those guys Isis hilarious my
own business and then watched a car
comes by thing as her husband or friend
then hits the goose oh hell yeah oh [ __ ]
he almost hit I know
get out dude he's like in the car
hey dude get out but also lady the guy
fell down - I'm not ever ever afraid of
a goose now let's you see me on camera
running from Zeus punch me with a job
[ __ ] you let me in well I would that I
would get out and go after that goose
right now I'll grab it I don't want to
hurt it I would just [ __ ] what I know
well I have a side I do this I'd like to
be doing this [ __ ] you've got in the car
I was scared was that guy guarantee
who's wearing a mask blue you dumb goose
knows goose get aggressive man they get
aggressive I got chased by turkeys same
[ __ ] oh yeah I've been chased by chased
by a goose like that this gave me - yeah
nature goes drop dude I [ __ ] book yep
I hit that 40 on that [ __ ] gear now
think about it bear ah that's game over
or just a big horse or a [ __ ] Buffalo
I'll put myself around that [ __ ] see the
Buffalo hit that girl I think campaigns
posted it I bet well they're like oh
this puffle is cute that's a giant
thousand-pound Buffalo buffalo goes hey
dude get off my [ __ ] land he goes of
course my dad was reading him the
newspaper I just hear him go god damn it
god damn just bison charters a nine year
old girl she was okay by I thank God she
was okay where the Bison came running
terrifying moments for a group visiting
Yellowstone National why are you this
close to the sales feet away charging
its target my gosh madessa Florida was
part of a group of about 50 people who
were visiting the Old Faithful geyser
area Monday afternoon you can see in
this video the group walking on a nearby
road nobody's only 5 to 10 feet away all
of a sudden you see it move running
toward the group tossing the little girl
into the air people don't understand
when I go to these wildlife parks that
this is wildlife this is not domestic
laws the nine-year-old was treated at
the Old Faithful clinic and release
thank God recovering this morning a gun
it's a [ __ ] disaster but parents why
are you letting a nine-year-old you know
I would 10 feet of a [ __ ] Buffalo I
don't that's what I mean it's so stupid
that is a [ __ ] Hill says Harry bull
that's a bull Buffalo man I wouldn't do
that with a domestic bull they're
dangerous I went to her with any animal
and and [ __ ] man that's so insane that's
that's that kind of [ __ ] and my father
goes god damn Iowa this these Japanese
tourists they put their little baby on
top of the Buffalo they put the baby
their little kid on the top of the
Buffalo anybody has kids knows what a
disaster than what happened yeah kid was
killed
no well you're full of good news today
no and so is that so is the father
whatever
of course it's Buffalo doing Buffalo
[ __ ] Buffalo dumb about my [ __ ] you
gotta be so you just kiss on the hands I
like how the parents just [ __ ] ditch
the kid run [ __ ] [ __ ] well yes that's
why you have to kill all the Buffaloes
there I said
it is nice this is a like last week I
think it was do you know do you
recognize this player yeah he played for
the Lakers okay
so Shannon Brown it's a weird incident
where two people they saw his house have
a for sale sign on it and they're
looking at houses so they walked towards
it to look at the house and then he was
like according to him he's like come
come inside come inside so then you
talked to them and they let them go and
then he started shooting like five or
six shots at them there's a woman in a
man so you got arrested for that
chocolate CT cuz no CDA might be more to
the story I had J said a bunch of people
sent emails of corn death that happened
and I think Georgia that guy that guy
got shot yeah yeah yeah the footage
shows him sneaking around house and then
running and running real fast so who
knows what happened then but I mean
still like I said just dude know how
please go for that but there yeah
definitely call the police but there's a
bunch of footage of him sneaking not
sneaking but look into multiple houses
sure and there's a burglar on the loose
but maybe again you know if you should
to me in the back for stealing your TV
or nahshon in the chest first the shot
in the chest because they approached him
with a shotgun he tried moving the
shotgun shot it's more woman footage
yeah Jay goes we got ton of this people
I guess they looked more into it like I
don't need looking more into it these
civilians took into their hands to
prosecute this guy and kill him
yeah with a shotgun yeah was he did he
have a weapon no was he raping somebody
no is he killing somebody no he was he
was acting suspicious in a neighborhood
we shoot him and shot over the chest so
if you're defending that you don't know
what the [ __ ] you're doing and the
reason that we have laws like that and
the reason you go to jail for that is
there's a very good reason to pay taxes
for people yeah because you know you
everybody could be doing whatever and
then if you leave it up to a couple of
vigilantes so don't be dumb what else we
get you do you sent this to me a little
while ago
Jason ethology is so I guess there's a
business where you take sexy models who
have some sort of experience in a salon
or haircutting
and then you rent time with them to show
you how to cut your hair online yeah I
guess that's just business the business
they're doing I didn't read all the way
through but it seems like that's the
business yeah so I am live.com a site
that offers a large a large variety of
adult web cam experience in Esther day
and launch of sexy cuts unique adult
camming experience that allows users to
consult with host models now if you're
cutting knowledge of for assistance and
cutting their own hip here the new
offering which we kicked off his site
with a party on may 8th is made
available to help men look their best
while staying quarantined
it sounds about you guys jackin I was
gonna say it sounds like it sounds more
like and for an extra tip I'll suck your
dick
that's what it was sounds like you're
both video be a video cam video only so
you have to get your tits up wait so
it's video and they come with a they
tell you how to cut your hair what a
terrible idea
safety cap barber show party look at
this let me see something
I mean butthole oh I was thinking about
90 day fiancé so I don't know have you
watched remember that 60 year old guy
who has that Robbie brownie to hots can
get it what remember that that 90
fiance's a 60 year old who's got llama
the girl he spent a hundred thousand
dollars
no Russian yeah of course she'll never
she'd it only through like some dating
site where that he's done once or three
times she still above me
finally finally he went to her he got
her address I went knocked on her door
this [ __ ] tool and what happened this
dumb dumb he hired a private
investigator like there's multiple
figure cousin exist and then he gets
there and hold on oh my god he met her
alright David and a lot of finally meet
in person after multiple failed attempts
and the bomb show up is that David seen
absolutely Wow approached from a
distance is that her dave says nervously
that's her Paul my host [ __ ] and she
hugged them alright go back huh yeah
this is incredible hi warm embrace spins
are in a circle why she sustained him up
so anything he [ __ ] I mean then David
says nothing the past even matters
because he spent a hologram
scroll down and previous few episodes
date flood to Ukraine was he actually
talking to her now it's the question
most apparently keep scrolling down
that's it
dance are they together or looks like it
well just that one time yeah I found it
he found his his Russian teacup yeah
right I'm sure she found out she was
gonna do a show look at her we'll get
him
he's a looks great for 62 it's a faux
leather jacket but yeah yeah great for
60 how about she stood them up all these
times and finally his ass hunted her
down damn good job dude that might be
what a love story nothing past matters
just so I just want enough to oh my god
that's her it worked see Brian is hope
dude you know what set your sights it
might take you a hundred grand in seven
years she'll set me up four times up you
can do it get a faux leather jacket
jacket man wow I can't believe founder
and she's like Gary dude I guess let's
do this
Wow [ __ ] yeah well yes that's pretty
much it
what's wrong with those lesbian couple
they were so annoying
this one always cries I was good no one
has a set of tits on it she's a dime
suggested Ted time yeah real hard she's
also not gay no I don't buy it either
now she's in a guy since she just
whatever yeah which one iced it's the
one on the right the one the left looks
like a piece of candy she's she's she's
got her sex with something sexy to or
two though that one's pretty they're
both pretty I think yeah already but
whatever so I know I
yeah listen uh mortgage because he went
and knocked on the door in an old man
can open the door and he's like I've
been living here since night she may be
polite but what's have you to start what
though this is about a divers
Oh a little Richard passed away too
you guys I'm sure you saw I thought he
was by 87 yeah 114 man you know his
sexuality never really came to light
even though he was a gay man 87 yeah uh
did you guys think he was passed away
already
I know I really did I know you know what
don't care yeah never crossed my when
you get when you had are alive you know
I mean 80 yeah we could play a game Dead
or Alive no idea I'm like I'm like that
dude looking for the Russian bride
you have no idea dude if you're older
you're damn 87 80 is 87 yeah there's an
article on her sexuality was very
interesting how it kind of went through
that especially in the seventies in the
hide rare you know you weren't so he was
such a it was almost like he was so
colorful that you expected him to be
everything it's like what gay looks like
that's the least of what it's like with
Queen yeah
the the band's name is Queen I now
straight men aren't gonna name the band
Queen true it's true I mean look at
Little Richard though what a unique dude
back in the day so - back in the day
when you were in Rome Italy and he was
amazing
keep dialing Miss Molly right yeah hell
yeah that's here Wow yeah must be
wearing makeup back then
tough but he was one of those guys it
was like [ __ ] it you know oh yeah tutti
frutti he well that's who do you think
Prince was copying yeah well they say
Prince wasn't gay though no that's like
bisexual I don't think so cheating type
it was Prince bye
and who knows what Prince was he was the
smallest person at our scene
huh-ah Tsaritsyn for each other a list
of bisexual people a through F Jesus
Christ all right kiss hell no and I
guess ends it I think that's it
party you think it's her Brian I doing a
show last last month in there last
weekend in May May 29th 12:30 a 31st get
you tickets laughing by myself finally
together
that's right baby boys back in town town
the boys and you stay on some covert
humor yeah I'm all right man that's it
the fun kid route